[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
courses in the world with the vista to
the alps why would you want to throw
that away
there has to be another way to support
the race course
in conclusion i just want to say hello
this is me
you're probably going to see a lot more
of me you're probably going to hear a
wee bit more from me
um and i just don't want this in our
community i want our community to be
beautiful to stay beautiful
thank you thanks tracy carolyn hi
my name is marilyn davison um i started
the petition in the library as i had a
number of queries from people
while working at citizen's advice who
knew about the online petition
but they did not have computers and
wanted to have a voice to say no to the
proposed quarry at the rangiwa
racecourse
i love living in ringyur and i am very
passionate about my community
i have three voluntary jobs as well as
being a jp
and love helping in the in the waimakiri
district
i'm very concerned about proposed quarry
and the effects it will have on the
mental states
health and well-being of the people in
the district due to noise and silica
dust pollution
most of us have been through the trauma
of the earthquakes especially those who
have us
have come from christchurch as well as
covert and we just want a peaceful life
i enjoy living in the quiet and tranquil
environment of rengura especially the
north west where we can go for walks and
enjoy the health and beauty of our
surroundings
this will not be the case if the quarry
proceeds
with the increase in traffic over the
last few years particularly milk and
logging trucks river road has been used
as an alternative route
rather than using west belt with the
proposed quarry targets are proposing
approximately 120
truckloads a day will use river road
there will also be
considerable rattling noise from empty
trucks coming back from the racecourse
and there is two concern from the amount
of trucks cutting up the roads
ring your blue line bus last week
commenced travelling along river road
onto west belt
which would have a huge impact on its
15-minute schedule
if held up by trucks coming and going
with both shingle and refill
what is proposed to prevent asbestos and
other unsuitable substances being
present in the backfill there is a
council bus
park and ride exchange being built on
river road which will also have an
impact
cyclists are able to travel there and
leave their bikes at the exchange
as we know trucks and cyclists do not
mix
there could also be school children
catching the bus from there
under their pdp submission targets are
proposing to regularly water down
where would all this water come from
especially as i understand there is
presently restricted water available
from the ashley river
something restricting urinary residents
current water use right now
a quarry would need large volumes of
water to even attempt to mitigate the
dust provided produced sorry
will this dust and silica eventually
lead to it contaminating adjacent
water wells nearby as has happened
widely in the christchurch area
will such water percolate down into the
existing subsoil water reserves
affecting its quality
would such contamination affect the
water quality of the ashley river
will the dust and silica not only affect
the health and well-being of large areas
of surrounding residential areas
but also impact on bird life around the
ashley river
and inevitably clearly also the horses
using the race course
the answer to these questions is quite
obvious of course it will
you have only to look at the impact of
existing quarries in christchurch
all locals are up in arms about the
effects of quarries in any area
let alone adjacent to intensive housing
the proposed quarry has already affected
house prices in the area
and i will and i will hand out a note
from a resident advising
excuse me of the loss of potential
buyers
who pulled out when they heard of the
quarry proposal mitigation cannot be
used
as an excuse to sneak this past council
quarries have produced very large
backlashes
from this presently being operated and
their claims cannot be
scientifically upheld we enjoy the race
course in its present form and support
its use
for the horse fraternity rather than
unpopular quarry advocates
there has also been a lot of thought go
into the neighborhood with the naming of
the surrounding streets
for example arlington escot and aintree
we do not want our peace shattered by
the constant noise and silica dust
pollution proposed for the next 15 years
and we should not be subjected to it
i understand there have already been
complaints from residents about the
noise and dust of targets machines
breaking rocks and crushing up shingle
at the cones road site which is
affecting their normal track walking
conditions silica dust is an established
health hazard
i suggest that a public notified consent
is granted because people over the
district are concerned
let the people who live here decide not
the paid consultants and ecan officials
who live elsewhere
let the people be heard thank you i do
have copies
of my presentation and the copy of the
lady
that's been affected by the proposals
thank you thank you good afternoon
ladies and gentlemen my name is jill
robinson
thank you for this opportunity to speak
to you all regarding our petitions
when i read in the paper and saw what
was proposed regarding the quarry at the
race course
i was angry we have loved living around
europe for over 10 years and greatly
appreciate the way the newer
subdivisions have been developed
to encourage people to walk in the areas
and for children to play and exercise
in the reserves nearby rita my neighbour
knocked on my door with a newspaper and
a hand and asked if i'd seen the map of
the proposed quarry
we were disgusted to think that the
trotting club and taggers
could have so little regard for their
neighbours that they would consider this
project
and for 15 years not the right place for
a quarry
and so near to housing and businesses we
were delighted that tracy had opened the
online patricia
petition but as rita said she and others
may not be able to access that
so we decided to go door-to-door no
you're sitting around moaning about it
we were overwhelmed at the response we
received from other equally angry
residents
and pleased that some had already signed
tracy's petition
we soon discovered that maryland had
also started a petition at the library
but thought the personal approach would
be good
we were thanked by so many people for
doing this and also
got a few hugs only a handful of people
thought that it would affect them
and didn't know enough about it to want
to sign up we also discovered
that some of the newest subdivisions in
the southwest had nobody delivering the
news or the northern outlook in the area
so they didn't know of the quarry
proposal so i went home and put
newspaper cuttings with the photos
and the propose of the proposed quarry
into my folder
these people couldn't believe that
they'd been allowed to build or buy
there
when the proposal had been lodged over
two years ago and no indication of the
proposed quarry
had shown up on their limb report these
residents didn't know that hundreds of
trucks carrying clean phil
to the quarry would be using lehman's
road for 15 years
i was particularly concerned for the
number of elderly people
who live in the north west of bangiora
many of whom like myself
have respiratory issues there are 600
people living in the charles up in
retirement village
and another 140 at ballarat retirement
village
then at the other end of the scale we
have a preschool and
um drive and another under construction
at oxford road trails up in corner
these little people will not be able to
play outside on certain days when dust
is flying
because of the wind direction nobody
will be able to open windows
on hot summer days or hang washing
outside all the nearby businesses will
be adversely affected by the quarry
do you want to drink your latte or pint
outdoors with the dust
and the deafening noise spoiling the
ambience i think not
just last week i drove past maringua
high school where the lawn was being
mined i couldn't believe the huge cloud
of dust
that crossed over wall street and then
over the next four houses to the west
the wind from the wet of the east was
nothing like the north westerlies that
we've recently had
and i wished i'd been able to take a
photo money
money money it all comes down to money
people associated with the race course
need the money win win win for them
take it earth moving only have to travel
1.5
kilometers to extract the aggregate that
they need
yay win win one for them two companies
win
while thousands of people who live
nearby lose
lose lose big time and will not be able
to sell their significantly devalued
homes
for who wants to live near a quarry the
resulting dust
and noise causing health issues and
massively
increased truck trailer activity on
river and lehman's roads
is just not on please please
please hear our plea and say no to this
quarry
thank you thank you
we've heard you loud and clear
um in terms of uh you had some material
you wanted to leave behind have you got
copies of submissions
can i just pass them on to somebody um
we might i'll give one of our staff will
get that from you
but before um for is there any questions
from colleagues
no questions oh sorry councillor evans
ah thank you for coming along and saying
no
i get the message um you mentioned
that the target application was lodged
two years ago
is that correct i've only heard about it
recently so
2018.
right the original application went in
then and it was also
on the application requested that it was
not publicly notified
as well all right thank you for that
thank you
ahead nick to duke
thank you originally
yeah again thank you for that
presentation um
with tracy um being the um probably
ringleader of this
um i just wondering whether you've had
any communication with the trotting club
to
um see if you can assist in some
thoughts and ideas for them
for raising money for they're not
interested they're not interested
no i spoke to the delightful president
of the trotting club at the target's
presentation
wednesday week ago um they're not
interested they're not interested in
exploring any other options this is the
only option
and i more or less got told yeah that's
it the only alternative for them
yep thank you
sorry councillor blacky followed by
councillor pilot um
excellent um methodology and doing your
door-to-door and your local presentation
just a bit um
interested in in the petition um
hundreds of
um submissions from auckland and from
spain and
from the philippines how much weight do
you put on a
on these on these foreign people um
having having
opinions on what we do in north
canterbury well
it depends um i don't know that they're
not related to somebody who lives here
i don't know that there no it doesn't
and i don't know that they're not a
mother daughter
sister that they haven't lived here
they're not planning on moving here we
don't know that
so the fact is it's online it's open to
a
multitude of different people they felt
strongly enough to sign it and have an
opinion
so i'm all for that the majority of the
signatures came from
the area uh in christchurch a lot of
people signed christchurch when they
were actually in rangiora
so that doesn't reflect their locality
very well either so look it's an online
petition it's open to everybody they're
entitled to their opinion
and their opinion is quite loud and
clear which is a no
thank you councilman just two questions
one actually just
clarification mr harrison if i may when
does
um an application go on to the limb of a
property
at what point um
an application right
so it doesn't go on even if it's been
accepted by the council at all
at any stage or it's going to hearing on
a limb
right but it wouldn't be until it's
right at the end of the process
thank you and just just a question to
the panel and thank you very much for
your presentation
were you aware that the council operates
in two very separate areas one is
regulatory
and one is the this body that you see
here today and
and it's a regulatory arm that make the
decisions that you're talking about
you are aware of that um what's your
understanding of the resource consent
process
oh that's too long okay that's all good
we don't expect you to know right i just
wondered if you'd i do
understand that it's under review and
that yeah they're looking at it because
it is a very complex
it's a very complicated consciousness so
we've got people involved in our group
who
are well-versed with that right we're
kind of great the voice we've been out
there in the public eye we're the people
there
that people know and have seen and
spoken to about it
so we're kind of sticking with that we
leave the
the harder things to the the people who
have the
experience and expertise for that but
there are lots of people involved
lawyers
um all sorts of people involved with our
group now
right but were you aware that it's not
this body that makes the decision on
notification
thank you thank you
thank you any further questions all
right uh look thank you marilyn jill and
tracy
um for being passionate and and coming
along today
you mentioned before um tracy that you
know
you may be here you're welcome any time
so with many of our ratepayers any time
to come
and let their opinion be known that's
what democracy is all about and local
democracy
so your opinions are important to us
um so that finishes the deputation so if
you'd like to you're welcome to rejoin
and just take a seat there as i said i'm
going to bring the item forward
robbie do you think you could just turn
off the microphone oh sorry thank you
tracy
i'm going to bring forward item 14.1
which is under correspondence so there
is no report with us so it's just a
recommendation so
i'll move from the chair the
recommendation to have someone prepared
to
second seconded by council williams so
just speaking briefly to it it's just to
say
thank you for the efforts of
those who organise the petitions to
bring forward the community's opinion
um to to our council for its
consideration
was mentioned before about change.org
and the different mechanisms that were
bought
it gives a snapshot of the community's
opinion and
when i was looking through those
petitions too i did notice that there
was people that put christchurch
and there are people i very well knew
lived here so
um but it's as a guide of the
community's opinion in a strongly filled
opinion i've had many people approach me
uh who all have been to see me and
certainly left me in no doubt of
their opinion on the matter and as i
said before it's the heart of democracy
people coming
and letting their views be known
and i met with you all a few weeks ago
and
along with the community board chair um
rangity community board
chair jim jarrod so the recommendation
today is that we receive the
petition but we refer it to council's
planning manager
and the rangiora ashley community board
because they are the appropriate
parties to actually take this forward
and take note of it
in future processes you mentioned around
the notification process my
understanding from
attending the drop-in and also seeing
the material from
targets that targets are offering that
it now be publicly notified once
the application's compliant and my
understanding mr
mr um harrison be able to correct me
differently but we don't have a
complying application at this point
so uh once that's received it'll go
through its process of consideration
um it's not an approach it's not
appropriate for me or our counselors to
express an opinion
on an application that comes to us we've
got to maintain an open mind
through this process it's got to go
through its process
uh and the account survey that was
appropriately asked just just letting
you know that before
around that but and and having met with
you i think you're all quite well-versed
and
probably better than you were beforehand
of process around resource consent so
look
on behalf of the council thank you for
your efforts
to bring forward the community's opinion
and we appreciate your time today
council williams i like to
endorse everything that the mayor said
on it it's good to have
feedback from the um public and the um
the side of the petition and all that
drama it's probably not
much that we um already knew was going
to be
happening with the um rape paths around
there so um
it's just you know good to see you
active and
bring that to our attention any further
speakers
uh council duty that's right
uh i just noticed that when i was
looking through your submissions there
were a lot that were crossed off so
you've done
a lot of work to check on make sure
there was no double
yeah and i can and i congratulate you
all on doing that because so many
petitions do
have a double up so i really appreciate
the hard work you've put through onto it
yeah thank you thank you council
followed by council steward yes i want
to say congratulations ladies on our job
very well done this is democracy in
action this is our public
speaking and it's interesting that
taggets have now come forward
offering public notifications so that
may not have happened unless there was
some pressure put to be so
i think you're achieving your aim as it
is and
i look forward to seeing how the process
works through thank you
here's councilman council stuart
oh okay right
okay um further speakers i'm not going
to exercise and write reply
so i'll put the recommendation all those
in favor please say aye
contrary and declare that carried thank
you
all right we'll now move back to
[Music]
uh item um six um
an item six point one which is the
cowboy storm water and flood
improvements that's
mr sorry harriet davies and jared
is it just you jared
oh you've got a team right
right
name is on the report as well as harriet
um but as you
will probably be aware there's a lot
more people um
preparing this work than than uh
just us so look um i'll give
i'll give a brief introduction to the
report
and talk about the key things that we're
wanting to get signed off
today um and then uh we're happy to take
take any questions so really this is
actually quite an important milestone
for this shovel ready project you'll
recall during the
um covert 19 period we put a bid into
the government to secure
co-funding for the flooding and
stormwater improvements
in kaiapoi and we were ultimately
successful with that
bid we had to be reasonably specific in
that bit in terms of what the work was
and so we are staying true to that in
the work
program so just to give you a quick
overview of the work there's really um
three big uh pump stations
that are the core of this project one in
the otaki street area which is an area
that we've had quite a lot of flooding
in the past
so that's a pump station plus a pipeline
out to the kaipoi
river including what we call interceptor
pipe work so that's gravity pipes that
will bring
water to that pumping station from
both the dudley drain and the other
surrounding urban areas
the next project is the beach road pump
station
and rising main and feldwick stormwater
management area
so that's basically building a pump
station
at on just near beach road up on
feldwick drain
uh for those of you who know it's where
there's currently a 90 degree angle in
that
drain and so that'll actually provide a
um a good
high capacity stormwater pump station to
serve the urban part of kaiapoi on that
on that eastern side of kaiapoi
um and that also involves stormwater
treatment in that
sma area and the last one is a
pump station at macintosh's drain and
so that macintosh's drain serves the
whole catchment right up toward end
and during very large storm events we do
get water spilling out of that
macintosh's catchment into the urban
parts of kaiapoi
so that project goes hand in hand with
the feldwick
drain project to help provide capacity
into that part of
kaiapoi so
this what we're looking for in this
report is primarily boils down to the
resolutions f and
i so f is
refers to the procurement strategy and
that basically
um gives you an austere in terms of how
we're going to
chop this project up into size
uh parcels of work that can be delivered
and we think it's the best way
to deliver it and provide opportunities
for
the contractors who work in our district
and also to put that in a manageable
scale so we think we can get the best
value for the council
at that kind of a scale and this the
resolution i
is uh delegating authority to the chief
executive and myself
to sign off the final due diligence
and funding agreement with otakuro and
those are
attached to the report we're quite keen
to get this
in and going we've already started work
on the design
but the sooner we can get that signed
off and
confirmed uh there will be some of these
pieces
of work that if we can get to the market
early um we want to try and
try and get that out as soon as we can
and you'll and you'll see from the
um report there's a pretty tight time
frame over this
whole thing so look uh kelly rob and i
are happy to take any
questions on that thanks jared
uh kelly and rob did you have any
question
okay questions so counselor duty not the
council awards sorry
council duty that's all right i'll
remember
council 31st thank you thank you
thanks very much for this very good
report um
18 million do you hopefully think that
this will achieve all the flooding
in our district from that live catchment
area
solve that problem
um it will go a long way
it'll provide a signif it will provide a
significant
level of service improvement in that
area so
you will recall in 2014 we had many days
of flooding in the otaki street area and
the surrounding streets
in the feldwick catchment we have
ongoing flooding issues in the
likes of bracebridge street and meadow
street
and backing up into the back of williams
street so
it'll provide a huge improvement to
those areas
now this it's really important
to sort of be aware that there are
pockets of flooding through the whole
district including in kaiapoi
that may not necessarily get any direct
benefit from this this
this goes a long way to doing that and
there may be um but there
certainly i wouldn't be brave enough to
give you a statement that's going to
solve all of the
flooding issues um and it really
it and it only goes to a certain level
of service so when we
uh in in the storms that you could
anticipate so the
one year five year even 50-year events
it will definitely provide
quite a lot even the 100 year floods
where the stock banks hold it provides
quite an improvement
it also actually helps to future-proof
kyopou stormwater system
so we're making allowance for sea level
rise
in this project because we do know there
will continue to be further challenges
out into the future so this will help
um in that uh kaiapoi
um as does many coastal towns and and
towns on river plains does face
very large flood risks from say we had a
major river breakout
this is not designed to to to manage
with a
a event like that we're relying on the
stop banks on the ashley river and
kaiapoi river and the waimakariri river
and those kind of events
so look it's it's a huge improvement uh
but it's definitely not a silver bullet
to
resolve all of the flooding issues in
that area
mr b just one more question um
just uh talking about further the water
that uh
comes from mandeville
and ahoka that won't be will that be
flying into the air to help alleviate
some of
the flooding as well or not down down
down through to cairo area
um the the the water that comes down
from mandeville and
ohoka comes in through the silver stream
and the ohoka stream
now they discharge into the kaiapoi
river just to the west
of kaiapoi um so
that doesn't this this doesn't address
that that
that flooding in those areas the one
thing it does do
the work in otaki street that is
connected into
the parnums drain system and
so although we're not specifically
referring to a partners drain
pump station this actually provides a
lot of relief and capacity for partners
drain
and parnum's drain uh also
serves the rural area to the it's really
to the south
west of kaiapoi so island road up to
kendall park in
that area so that all drains into
parnum's drain under the motorway
um and also from that snead street area
so there it does take on some rural
catchment
thank you at concern followed by
williams and brian
thank you mr stewart sorry um and just
given that uh often we're held up by
third-party decisions
i know um we've got stop banks to deal
with and
going under rivers and and so on and
what has the
preliminary discussions with with the
likes of
ecan and and other parties such as power
and
so on what's the preliminaries and
indications from them on timelines
so we've had preliminary discussions
with uh can
main power and a number of other of the
of the authorities so we're underway
with those they've all been pretty
positive um you might be
aware that environment canberra are
planning some improvements to their
stock banks down by macintosh drains so
they are keen to work with us
in relation to that as well so i think
the incentives
for ecan are in the right direction as
well the one that we haven't
fully tackled yet is kiwi rail and so
that's that's one that
i'm very aware of as still remains a
risk for us but
the other discussions have been very
positive today
uh councillor williams
oh yeah that's a good project to get
done for particularly for the um
the woodlogged areas of carpool um
running these pumps will be quite
expensive have we looked into the
viability of actually um having some
solar panels there that um
when they're not being used and pumping
back into the grid
and just looking at the economics of
whether it's a viable thing for a solar
in the series
so effectively we end up with two new
pump stations so that's the
otechi flood pump station of sorry three
new pump stations so the otaki flood
pump station the fabric flood
pump station and macintosh flood station
so the nature of these pump stations
is that um they're not there for your
normal
rainfall events only for more
significant rainfall events and
we're expecting they're only going to be
used maybe
uh three four five times a year
um and they'll be operating at times
when
it's raining so we've actually got a
storm event so
and the actual power demand on them
is um not something you would be able to
service from a solar array and the
challenge that we've actually got is
working with main power to make sure
that the
electricity grid is robust enough to be
able to
just the high kilowatt demand for these
pumps will actually cater for them
yeah now that wasn't quite what i was
meaning what i was meaning was
um when they're not in use
if we wiring up these pumps
stations and all that now um there's not
much extra putting the extra wiring to
run solar panels so we can actually
get a credit from these stations while
we're not
actually pumping that's what i was
trying to get at whether it's a viable
thing to do that
and um get a credit on some of our other
power usage i know the
solar couldn't run the um the actual
pumps but it's uh
while we're wiring it up we've got a
significant very good question that
you've asked
just a few seconds ago
the reality is where these are being
located we're trying to
minimize the impact and footprint um of
these
so we but we have been
um as you'll be aware looking at
opportunities such as our rangiora
wastewater treatment plant where we've
got
areas of land that's also coupled with a
high demand
and able to be linked into the
electricity network
so we're looking for those opportunities
um and
they are sort of certainly part of our
longer term
strategy that this project and these
sites
wouldn't um i don't think they would
actually provide us with a lot of uh
benefit um from a solar generation point
of view
and and one last question i'll presume
he would look into the um
the underground boring to alleviate the
railway
problems of digging across here
casabran thank you with the benefits
that these projects
will bring is there any chance that
there could be a reconsideration as far
as floor
levels in the recently released hundred
year flood hazard
foundation levels having to rise to
ridiculous heights
um yeah that's a really good question
we're
in our latest latest iteration of the
flood
modeling we have allowed for the primary
systems
in the likes of rangiora and kaiapoi to
be operating so we
earlier models that we had the big flood
maps they didn't allow for the things
like pipes and pump stations
um this does uh for
the mo for the there are these
particulars particularly the otaki
street
area um this actually does give us a
much higher level of confidence about
the freeboard
so we're
so the flood maps themselves will be
based on the primary systems the ones
we've got at the moment
are based on the system that we've got
operating at the moment
so in future iterations we'll take into
consideration
these these pipe pipes and pumps
but already we have
because we do deal with live building
consents all of the time
um we've uh in that area been able to
take a lower freeboard allowance than we
had previously been anticipating
um which actually does directly relate
to
um lower house levels so uh
so yes um but for the for the majority
of people
um it it won't make
a huge amount of difference but in some
situations and some of those lower lying
areas that
they will potentially be able to build
at a lower level
thank you and so their limbs will
reflect that somebody just recently got
a limb
which reflects the new levels
any current limbs will not reflect the
um this it wouldn't be until the works
are complete
we've been through a modeling round um
following that
so it would in time it would work its
way through to them
okay council stuart
mr my questions are around the storm
water treatment
one first question will this
um project require
new consents for discharge into the
kaiapoi river and will they your
discharge would be required to meet the
standards of the
mps the pierce and fresh water package
so we're just working through the
consenting requirements
at the moment and we're expecting a
summary of those to come back
in the next day or two we're
anticipating that
it won't require new consensus because
we're not changing
new discharge consents because we're not
changing the the water going into into
the river
that's it the the smas will provide
obviously the benefits that they do
to the quality of the water going out
you're going to be sure of that because
the
existing consents are going to require
upgrading because you don't meet
the required standard of discharge at
the moment with what we've got going in
there and
the kaibu river is a now recognized
degraded water body
under the mps so you're adding more
probably of the same treatment standard
as existing or perhaps hopefully better
but you've got a you've got problems
that already existing in a degraded
body yes so i think in
terms of um for the pump stations that
we're putting in that are taking our
normal base flows for our um you know so
our dudley pump station and our
failboat pump station so if you take
fabric we're proposing a storm water
management area
to to treat the first flush flow for
dudley we're not at the moment um and
you're right
that doesn't change the current
situation
um and based on our network discharge
consent for chi
poi there may be a time in the future
that we need to come back and look at
how do we actually reach retrofit
treatment for the
dudley catchment so
we have to have a stormwater management
plan in place by 2025
so that that will be based on our
baseline monitoring it will set out
between 2025 and 2040 how we actually
then
upgrade the system to provide
treatment in place to achieve what's in
the atlanta water regional plan
hey sandra could you put your microphone
on people are starting to hear yeah
that um the the news
out of the hearings pc7 is that
the new fresh water package is to be
given effect to
as of now so how does that affect
the time frame for your stool motor
management
and upgrade in this particular edition
in terms of time frame we're still
working to the same
time frame so the next five years is
looking at baseline monitoring and
developing our stormwater management
plan
that will then sit in process
effectively a 10 to 15 year
period of upgrading to achieve water
quality standards and that's where we've
got our significant spin within the
budget
in terms of stormwater quality is from
2025
2026 onwards
council atkinson just just further on
that are we actually
talking about adding more storm water to
the river or are we
channeling the existing problem so that
it gets to the right place because my
understanding is it goes there anyway
it just may take longer and go through
people's houses which is not what we
wanted to do
is my understanding correct correct
thank you for clarifying that any
further questions
counselor redmond thank you mr mayor
um do the new proposed pumping stations
include backup generators with them
following on from councillor william's
suggestion of
solar energy i just wondered what
happens if the grid goes down
during a storm event
uh there is something that we haven't
considered yet
in any detail we don't have any
uh generators and permanently installed
at any of our stormwater pump stations
at the moment
and one of the challenges that we
actually have is because the
well some of the pumps are so large they
actually require
quite big generators to be able to um
to to start them in the first place
that's actually mainly starting these
pumps which is the biggest draw
on um the generators but that will be
a design consideration to look at um
if we did have a power outage and a
storm event
what should we be making provisions for
in terms of standby generation
further questions some appear to move
account council williams indicated you
have a second yep second hand by
accounts reconsider council williams
well i think this is a very good
significant um gain
with um getting government funding for
half of the project
and um it's very very good for the
people of getting wet houses or close to
wet houses and carp at the moment
so water does come downhill so
um affects quite a bit of the
waimakariri area so
well done
yeah look this is um this is certainly
worth doing
it's a very flat area through there
rather than an actual low area it
doesn't
doesn't go anywhere it's been proved
many times in fact i remember
when kelly not long after he came on
board meeting him down
just down from mahoka road um in his
vehicle in a pretty big storm event that
was involved and i think it was baptism
by fire for you then kelly
um and and the explanation of how flat
it was through there so
it's just how nature sometimes needs a
helping hand if it wasn't for
the funding that we have we wouldn't be
improving this and
um it would be a long way away because
it is a huge cost
and it's beneficial for everybody to
make sure that
water does go in the right place when it
goes somewhere
as opposed to letting it lie around and
and do its thing that people get pretty
pretty angry about
certainly when it's messing up their new
shag pile carpet
so um i think that this is it's it's
long overdue
but understand why it's long overdue and
that is the the problem has
always been a pretty big one and a
pretty big one to fund no matter which
year you're in so
this is going to allow us to do it and
it will make a huge difference certainly
up around
lots of other areas too relieve one area
will help relieve a whole lot so i think
this is well worthwhile
thank you and i agree with the comments
that have been made it's
very worthwhile and looked uh top marks
to our staff
and getting this project included within
the
shovel ready projects albeit that it
comes
as a 50 50 partnership it was always
going to be a
large capital project and every time it
rained down there i know that we're
always nervous about
particularly at that particular part
where there has known flooding issues so
this is certainly going to improve that
it's great that you've secured rob um
jared and kelly um it's good to have you
back on board and in a different role
but
this is clearly your area of expertise
and and from our perspective we're
securing um key staff like rob to help
us with all the projects that we've got
coming up
um it's really good so um it's good
getting ahead of that because there's
going to be a lot of
i would say capacity issues within the
industry
and so having someone on staff that
knows what they're doing
and can help us pull this together is
great and i think our community
we've live talk to are really i'm very
pleased to see
um that this project is finally going to
get over the line that's going to reduce
those flooding related issues and
stormwater issues that
have clearly been identified so job well
done look forward to seeing the project
completed and
on track thank you any further speakers
uh council meetings
i'd like to throw my two cents in worth
there as as the wife of a
a man whose family has lived in kaiapoi
for over 100 years
there are places that my father-in-law
and family have said that you know
never by there or there because it's wet
you know that's been a long-standing
issue for kaya poi and as kai boy has
grown it's
been a constraint and i think that
getting this project
up and running and over the line is just
a fantastic thing for the kaipor
community
and i tip my hat to you all and wish you
all the best
in getting it done and i look forward to
seeing the progress
thank you thank you further speakers
write reply council williams so i'll put
the recommendation
uh all those a favor please say aye
contrary
to clear that carried thanks team
nice we have no reports under
regeneration
we come to report uh
under uh items under reports 8.1
the adoption of the annual report for
the year mr millwood
thank you
thanks chief
cheers
all right okay uh i've just dropped off
the
ordered opinion for the annual report
the main part of the report and the
summary
as part of the adoption of the annual
report you're actually adopting the
auditor's report as well
reported in the
uh to the audit and risk committee the
um
the annual report this year has been
affected quite greatly by
covert 19 and we considered a
number of those effects within the
annual plan for this
this year that we're currently in at the
moment by making the provision
in the accounts with 2.1 million a
number of the
results have been affected by that
however the good result
in the annual report is the
non-financial performance measures which
is very similar to the previous year
about 73 there was two measures in the
in hindsight which probably should have
been
tagged for later and they've been
identified for
later completion
and we've also taken on note from
previous uh in your report that some of
the measures we we
do ourselves hard by the measures we put
in there by saying we'll achieve 100
percent for instance
building consensus resource consents so
we'll be looking at those
measures in the coming ltp to make them
a little bit more realistic
and to some degree achievable that sort
of
represents the fair performance of the
council
in the annual report audit of the audit
report there
which was completed today signed off by
the mayor and chief executive
it identifies two key differences to
previous order reports
one is in relation to page 133
note 16 in our investment property where
the valuer
identified that the market conditions
made that very difficult to assess a
value
and so that's noted in the annual report
as well in that note
and noted in the auditor's report
that investment land the bulk of that
investment lane
refers to our regeneration land and the
mixed business use
the other thing that you'll see
differently is a covered
note from the auditors and you'll see in
note 32 to the annual report
there's an extensive note there that
actually
details the decisions that were made by
the council in the annual plan and the
effects that
we thought covert would have on us which
uh
most councils or probably all councils
in new zealand will be doing that
putting that note in
to our council it probably hasn't had an
effect to some
the same extent of other councils but
the annual report there is uh for
adoption
um i've noted the variances uh
in the income and expenditure there's
also a note in the account
for major variances it's note 31 and
that gives you a little bit more detail
i'm happy to take any questions
thanks mr millwood uh any questions
councilman followed by councillor becky
two questions from me jeff and the first
race
first question is why isn't there a
report from the chief executive in our
annual report as
as is in most directors reports
perhaps that's a question for the chief
executive yeah um
and and
late in the pe we drafted we drafted a
there's a little bit of a drafting
oversight i suppose and uh
there was a statement that got drafted
that was
headed from the chief executive mayor
and chief executive
and um was co-signed but it actually got
written in the first person from the
mirror and at the last minute when we
were reviewing that
that's not going to work and it would
either require us to totally
redraft it again or create a
or create a new document and i made an
executive decision
that perhaps the report should be just
from the mayor
and uh and it went out like that so um
that was that was why it's like it is um
and it's not you know it is
normal for it to be a mayor and chief
executive statement but
at the last hours or so of um
production um that was the most
expedient thing to do to make it
read and look right so
you're saying it's already been printed
before we've approved it
it's been the the the
today you're adopting the annual report
including the auditor's
opinion so that is that is you have that
you have the ability of the council if
you want to to go back and
amend your annual report there's quite a
process to do that
um but if you wanted to do that that
would be um
quite a um well it would require a bit
of
real good effort with the auditors and
they'd probably end up
reissuing another opinion which would be
will come at a cost
so i i wouldn't recommend you do that
but
uh they are choices that are always
within your
um amber the annual report is still
in my view materially correct and if if
i had
co-authored well i i did uh co-author
and or review the statement um i'm
absolutely happy with the statements in
it and would have heavily have my names
uh attached to it if it was written in a
text
in a in a context that made sense
along those lines i'm just disappointed
your photo's not in it
yeah yeah yeah that
is that is that is one of the minor edit
that is one of the minor
if authorizes manager finance and
business support and chief executive to
make minor edits and corrections
so so could one of the minor if edits at
least perhaps on the compliance page
have your photo in the actual document
because you your photo doesn't appear
and yet you've done most of the work
[Laughter]
everybody else does the work let's be
clear
all right and so my second question
relates to the content a lot more
there's at least 17 parts of the big
annual report
that have read boxes saying we haven't
achieved and you've explained some of
them and
100 compliance and some of them are
covered but the forward doesn't reflect
that
particularly well or explain it very
well it sounds like we're doing
everything rosy
if someone looks at their report do you
think they're going to look at those red
boxes and say this council actually
hasn't
achieved in 20 19 20. no i don't think
so
i think the the actual statement right
at the front
of the overall performance we've put
that as a summary at the front which
um there's two pie graphs here that
highlight that
and show that quite clearly
we can't do anything else if we changed
it to it from a
green to an orange you know
it wouldn't fully reflect it and we've
been down that path with the auditors
before it either passes and gets
achieved
or it doesn't um and yes
we've been unfair to ourselves in all of
those areas
so someone looking at would say we've
achieved 75
but if you realistically look at them
we're somewhere near the 90 percent in
some of those measures
so you're saying the annual reports
really written more for the auditors and
for the general community
no i wouldn't say either
[Laughter]
council blocking chief um
we have a um a taxable surplus there of
2.8
what what at what rate is a council
taxed
okay so uh that taxes uh that is
sitting here is more in relation to the
associates and the group accounts
and they'll be taxed at the 30 cents in
the dollar yeah
the council
is also subject to tax on some of its
activities but generally they run at a
loss
so we don't actually have to pay tax as
such
there is a tax deduction that we make
for some of our dividends
and generally that's offset with uh
imputation credits
and therefore it's a no result generally
for ourselves
we as jeff says we are actually taxable
just that the large amount of our income
is actually exempt
or activity is exempt but there are some
activities
that actually particularly if we were
trading uh in a development space
those type of activities they are the
ones that actually
come within the tax umbrella
further questions we have a
recommendation i'll move from the chair
is there a second
second to buy a council blackheart could
i firstly say that i'm
i'm very proud of our organisation and
i think we justified we should be
looking at our performance there's
certainly some comments accounts about
it
just reflected there but if we look at
it in general
uh we've got a an ordered opinion today
which expresses an unmodified order
ordered opinion that's it's fantastic
goes along with
the fact that we're double a credit
rated a double a rated for our
performance as a council as well so
it's a huge um accolade for jeff and his
team
for jim for all who are involved in the
council and that's performance
points were made around the uh annual
report i i actually had no idea
that it was uh it was missing the chief
executive
in there and i would have always jim and
i worked very closely together
and we both reviewed that document and
certainly our comments were reflected in
there so i didn't realize that that had
been made but look the level of detail
that we're
over in the organization the points that
perhaps
i should have picked up on and will note
for
for the future uh when it comes to those
things coming to us so it's a good point
you've picked up on the accounts of
arnold but look in general
i think we can be very proud of our
performance particularly in light of
corona
covert 19 and other matters so thanks
jeff to you and your team to jim
and all involved uh council becky
council brian thank you and i've just
scanned the independent auditor's report
and would like to note under
other information the third third
paragraph uh which
is good just pull your microphone down
the middle of it sorry other other
information in the independent orders
report third paragraph
uh it's uh it's good reading
thank you cass reckinson oh uh any
further speakers
oh counts about it yes
thank you very much for this report and
it's it's always a shame that this comes
at the wrong timing for us in terms of
trying to pass
our report being early in the month um
the report is fantastic
um i believe that obviously most of the
community will probably only read the
summary
and um so i think it's really important
to get that summary right if we can for
the community
so that i thank the mayor for making
those comments um i just think it's a
real shame because it's the last year
that our chief executive
is with us and i would have very much
like to have had his
representation in the in the document
fully because it would be a tribute to
the the 17 years of service
um however i know he is very much part
of the document even if he isn't
specifically noted and
he hasn't got his photograph um the
important thing is that we have done a
good job
and as we've stated in many audit
reports
we are too hard on ourselves some of the
non-performance measures
are very very difficult to get 100 and
we've talked
at length about whether we should be
reducing that or whether we should be
allowing for that
one-off strange case that comes through
but often the auditor's
opinion doesn't allow for that and we
either have to meet it or not meet it
and nothing in the middle
so i'm very very proud of this report
i'm very very proud of what this council
has achieved
over 1920 with the challenges it's faced
i'm very proud of
the mayor for stepping into this breach
at a very difficult time
and chief executive for leading the team
so and of everyone
in this room and everyone in the
organization so thank you for producing
an excellent report and if there are any
questions on that i'm sure that the
commentary will speak for itself
thank you thank you
all right any further speakers
nothing to respond to i'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carried thank you
it might just
um just check that the door's closed in
the town or next door
we're getting a bit of a bit of base
which is good
you're almost wrapping there at that
stage kirsten
[Laughter]
all right
item 8.2 pages 166 to 202 capital
projects annual report
mr young joined by mr cleary
thank you mr mia after such a glowing
report received from jeff mill where
there's a less glowing one
in front of you at the moment um
the issues associated with the kevlar
works program i think have been well
voiced around this table and i think the
uh
the councillors will be very well aware
of the issues that we have been
facing and and trying to tackle in terms
of getting
an improved percentage of spend
the majority of the steps uh that the
manager utilizing roading
and the manager community and rick have
been taking over the last
18 months or so it takes a long time for
those to work their way through the
system and so what you're really seeing
at the moment
as i think a reflection of the
earlier processes that we had in place
in the thinking that was in place and
not to say they were bad
it's just that i think
as we've recognized in the past we have
at times been overly optimistic about
our ability to achieve works within a
financial year
we have allowed carryovers to build up
in front of us and potentially not
properly reflected that
and we've failed to recognize i think
the hugely
uh complicated tasks of getting some of
these works
across the line since that time
we've put in place a lot of processes so
that in this particular year
we effectively had all of the
task plans prepared
discussed signed and approved before the
financial year even started
and so we are a lot better
currently in terms of our projected
spend this year
and so we are feeling that a lot of the
issues that have underlined
this performance we have been dealing
with and and working on
through um the
roading program for this coming year of
course is is the big one
and that will always be a challenge for
us but we are working pretty hard on
that
with regard to last year's numbers
there's one more item i'd just like to
point out and that is
while we use exactly the same numbers as
the finance team
when it gets there is a
there is a little bit of a disconnect in
that our spreadsheets
what happens is at the end of the year
any works that we have spent
thinking it would be capitalized are
then
expensed out of our numbers so our
numbers will then
drop accordingly in terms of the amount
we have spent
with regard to the financial numbers
they are put back in because of course
it is actually a total project cost
whether it is expensed or capitalized it
is a project cost
so the effect of that is there is a
little bit of a misalignment and some
minor details
with regard to the underlying
spreadsheets
and the summary information which has
come directly from the finance team and
reflects
their uh overall council financial
situation
it is relatively minor but if you are
seeing some numbers that don't quite
match the underlying spreadsheets that's
the reason for that
um jared i'm not sure if you had
anything to add
um no i i i i just really want to
reinforce don's point
um we certainly you know i'm certainly
not proud
of the percentage that we've delivered
and
i'm feeling far more confident that
will achieve a far better outcome this
year
even with the additional work that we've
got on our
plate and the other point i would make
is it's
been thanks very much to a lot of don's
hard work
he's helped get up set up this reporting
system
get it in train and we will see the
benefits of that start to
flow through and my final point is
the responsibility for the delivery of
this program
lies with me and with chris brown um so
uh if you've got any um
concerns please see either me or chris
don's done a good job and
helping us track it but ultimately
that is where the responsibility lies in
and certainly i'll take responsibility
for the delivery from the utilities and
reading department
thank you uh don and jared any questions
tell us about it
just looking at page
it's not a page number the second page
of the report
4.3.2 and roading
you've listed some of the projects there
but
i'm just wondering shouldn't there be
some sort of commentary that a lot of
these
were absolutely out of our control and
due to nzta
delays rather than just
saying it's the engagement with
community and community boards
um look we i suppose in terms of putting
this together we just didn't want to
make it sound like we're making excuses
so yeah there is a lot there and if you
want to see the detail on them
it's in the sheets that sit in behind
them
but uh yeah look we we could
have put more justification and um i
have to say
uh i was quite conscious that i didn't
want to make it sound like a whole pile
of excuses
uh you know the at the end of the day uh
we haven't delivered the program look
there's a
huge number of reasons for them and many
of them are outside of our control
just just looking in this in the sheets
where does it say that some of these
were actually delayed by the council
due to covert 19. for example the
the lighting replacement it in in this
on the sheets i couldn't see anything
mentioned about it being a council
decision
council decision do you mean we delayed
a lot of
we've laid a lot of capital works on two
yeah because
so there were a number of them say for
example the lights where we just had
you know we had a huge stand down time
of several months and that
i either affected the supply chain um
and as well as the implementation and
installation and roading
you know we we lost the best
window that we do have for the roading
season
is just as an example where that's
that's the time that we're actually out
there
busy um putting the the uh
the bitumen and the hot mix on the road
and once we got out of lockdown we were
we were outside that weather window
thank you further questions uh
recommendation moved by council
reckinson seconded by council of other
councillor atkinson well
thank you for this report and don
particularly for the reporting
um you know i mean we were told when you
first embarked on this uh
this exercise that was going to take a
while to filter through
and in all of our well particularly my
criticism of the carryovers and and i
still believe we can get much better at
it i have
no doubt in my mind that we can get
better at it there are some that are out
of control and out of
uh sorry how to control out of our
control or
in other controls i'm talking about the
ones that we do control and that's what
i've always talked about
i i always get it thrown back in my face
that there are things out of our control
i know that i've been around this table
for 20 years i'm well aware
that those things happen and this
reporting has put
us as counsellors i believe in a much
better space to see exactly where we are
what we had before that used to come
through order was insufficient to tell
us where we were
and we now have that and and you're not
making excuses i
i well no one wants to see excuses
around the table if there are valid
reasons they are not excuses
so i accept it it's wonderful that at
your level you've taken on the
responsibility of
of of saying that but at the end of the
day if they're valid reasons their
reasons not excuses so
and that's and and that's what we're
looking for is just the honesty up front
of what
we have and what we don't have and what
we have is now
in my view that will filter through over
the next few years it's been what
18 months has it somewhere there abouts
two years that this might be the second
full report of this that we've had um
and it was expressed to us in the start
that it will take time to filter through
and
and i fully accept that so thank you for
that and um these are good honest
reports in front of us
there's nothing hidden in there anyone
if they want to have a good read of it
can see exactly where we are
thank you he's just endorsing councillor
atkinson's comments and
reasons not excuses we would like to
just know why
and this report gives us that
opportunity to delve down and find
exactly why
um and i think you've been dealt a
really bad hand i actually think you've
been way too hard on yourself
in this report particularly in roading
um there's always room for improvement
and we all know that but covert 19 has
put all our schedules out of work
and i i think the community will
understand that as much as any
what i didn't like was the comment about
it having to have the engagement with
community and community boards we've got
to factor that in
that's always going to happen and i
realize there are going to be some
sticky
points that come through there's going
to be some bits where we need to do a
little bit extra
so and we can't always predict that but
in this case i actually think the main
reason that this capital program is
delayed in some areas
is actually can be squarely put at
covert 19's feet
and the fact that we couldn't work in
the time that was the best time to work
for the year
so i actually want to say don't be hard
on yourself be
be upfront be honest give us this
information and we really thank you for
that openness
any further speakers i'd just like to
endorse those comments that have been
made i i think
uh there's been a lot of work going to
the capital program
thank you don thank you jared actually
for employing don
um because i think it was actually a
really inspired decision
that you made bringing on some of don's
capability as i mentioned at
another meeting that it's certainly i've
noted the performance and
the number of our departments go up
because of the oversight
and the guidance that's going to to more
junior staff
particularly as we go out in the public
area
and we're dealing with consultations
that are tricky um
don brings a um his years of experience
and that too that is is do you
um you yourself so uh i'm i'm not gonna
i think i agree with council obama
perhaps we are being a bit hard on
ourselves in some ways
tonight maybe an accurate reflection but
overlay all the other challenges we've
been through
in this period i think we're doing
pretty darn well so
um thank you team for to your both and
to your team for what you're doing and
it's a journey around this report annual
reporting and
as you mentioned we'll we'll see the uh
perhaps next year some improvements in
those areas but
as you've mentioned on the whole um
very well i'm pleased with the progress
that we're making so thank you
any further speakers right of reply
council atkinson
i'll put the recommendation all those in
favor please say aye
contrary declare that caring thank you
all right item no we're there at item
8.3
which is the notification of private
plane change 30 for ravenswood pages
203-338
trevor and karen please
good afternoon uh mere councillors uh
look i'm
happy to take the reporters read and i'm
happy to answer any questions that you
might have on this
particular plan change
okay anything from youtuber
i just briefly um i guess the issue of
business zonings and key activity
centers in the
warding pegasus area has been an
unresolved issue for a wee while
um certainly been identified through the
wooden strategy more recently the
district development strategy
and certainly ravens would have now
firmed up their views as to what they
want to do
hence the private plan change coming in
and looking to
change existing zonings and also pick up
the kac
notation that's been earmarked for that
area for some time
this report is just around accepting
the proposal not the merits of it
though we've given some indication that
there are some matters that we'll
probably need for the earring as part of
their process
thank you thank you questions
tell us about so
the reason that this notification
decision has come to us is due to the
significance of the
of the actual application uh it's a
requirement under the rma
in terms of once uh application comes to
it we need to take it to council to
uh make a determination whether or not
we accept adopt
or reject the plan change so this is the
um substantial nature of the report
and today's decision as you said does
not say accept or decline because it
hasn't been out to the public at all
yeah so absolutely and one of the things
that
we did we we got a draft version of
the plan change in august
and we believe that it needed some
strengthening
up in terms of actually identifying
exactly what they wanted to do
why and making sure that the evidence
was
at a sufficient status so that members
of the public could actually understand
what it was actually doing and why and
they've now made those changes and we
believe that it's at a sufficient
standard to notify
that doesn't necessarily mean based on a
decision of accepting it today
that council actually agrees with the
plan change it just means that it's
ready to
go out for public um submission and
comment on it and you'll note that we've
already highlighted the fact that we
have some concerns with the plan change
and that we will be uh making a
or recommending to council that we make
a submission to um resolve a number of
issues
and those are identified in the
recommendation and in the body of the
report
so the fact that the plan changes
suggesting that
ravens would become a stand-alone urban
area rather than part of wood end
is a matter that the council would
comment on
yeah so you might recall
we canvassed this issue as part of the
district development strategy
um and um i recall we had a
conversation in both pegasus and wood
end in terms of
where do we finally fall in this sort of
matter and
district development strategy signaled
that
council thought that it probably should
be ravenswood based
on probably a couple of factors one the
geographical sort of nature of it it is
basically
in between wood end and sort of pegasus
and then based on the ability for a
green field type development
that has the ability to provide retail
at a scale it seemed to be the most
logical
location for that um and
ravens would have jumped on that
sort of advice in the dds to
put forward this plan change as a whole
i mean on reflection it would be great
to
resolve this just in the district plan
review
and do it then but uh ravenswood has
sort of indicated to us that they are
seeing
a level of demand for retail that
may want to occur at a faster rate than
what the discipline review
might be able to achieve so that's why
they propose the plan change now rather
than waiting for the district plan
review
and the length that that might take to
resolve the issues
and one of the concerns that they sort
of had was if it's tied up with a
district plan review
you may not actually get a result for
another two or three years depending on
appeals whereas they could get this
resolved in the next sort of
six to 12 months
yeah that was actually going to be my
question is around whether it should
wait for district planned review but
it's a decision an applicant can make
that that's correct
and look we there are we do have the
option to
uh reject plan changes um and accept and
adopt the
reject sort of phrase where they have a
series of criteria
and we don't believe that just because
we're notifying a
district plan in the next six months is
is a good enough sort of
um requirement to meet those sort of
standards so
based on that the evidence and the
information is out of standard we
have a duty to recommend notification of
this plan change
irrespective of our wants or desires in
terms of that from a process point of
view
so cameron around recommendation f which
delegates to
the mayor and chair of district planning
and regulation which is council banners
um to sign off on the submission what is
the time frame around
a council submission and is there a
sufficient time in which to bring
a submission back to the council to
consider
i don't know how you feel councilman but
i feel a little uncomfortable signing
off something
the council hasn't had a view on i
wanted to
clarify the process and then happy to
make any amendments that council
feels necessary one of the things that
we were reflecting with matt and his
team around the summerset
plan change is aligning submission
processes with council meetings sort of
time periods
and a lot of the time you get to a point
where either one falls just outside of
the other process or another it doesn't
quite align
so what we wanted to do was to try and
draft up a
submission and then test it with
councillors be it the mayor and the
chair of the district plan regulatory
committee and then it would go
to council for full endorsement so
all it's trying to do is to allow us to
make a
submission and get some sense from
council from a delegation that you may
be
comfortable to at least in terms of the
the drafting and then
the full decision on whether or not the
submission is either accepted or
put forward uh would come to this full
council anyway
so it's a it's a timing sort of um
mechanism really to try and um get
things aligned
which is which is covered in g yeah
furthermore it's about
meeting statutory time frames as well um
obviously there's some expectations from
the
applicant around those and also just to
avoid
unreasonable delay bearing in mind
there's a submissions process
a further submissions process there's a
christmas period all those types of
factors coming through
so if we accept the plan today when
would you be bringing when would we need
to
or council need to provide a
or council submission to meet the time
frame
so we're looking to notify the plan no
later than the 30th of
october there's a little bit of process
just
before we finally notify it if it is
by the 30th it's 30 working
days 20 weekend days 20 working days so
we are getting close
to sort of december in terms of that so
the question is
if that aligns with the last council
meeting
then we can actually skip that process
in terms of what we were suggesting
um if it doesn't align then um
we're sort of caught in terms of cersei
is there any reason why a draft
couldn't come to the november council
meeting
which would then make sure then you're
in within time frame
could yeah make that work certainly be
my preference
um rather than signing off something on
behalf of the council but
okay i i will i'll listen to what you
have to move shortly
any further questions all right
councilman do you wish to move
with a slight change to eve
to delegate the mayor and chair of the
district planning and regulation
committee
to develop a council submission with
staff on plan
change 30 to bring to the november
council meeting
okay someone prepared to say and she has
accounts
yes when i read this plan change i
certainly i knew that
we knew that it was coming um we knew
that ravens would have got
clientele who are looking for
commercial land we have shortage of
large
format commercial land in our district
and some of this they are looking to
develop further retail
this is going to be an issue that's
actually affects quite a wide area of
our district
it affects our other key activity
centers in kaipuan rangiora
and we'll have to have careful
consideration about what the council
thinks is best
for the eastern part of our district
bearing in mind that wood end
is woody woody pegasus area is predicted
to reach
the size of kaiapoi with the
developments that are currently zoned
the major concern i have is that
ravenswood's
submission seems to be coming back and
changing our district plan
when we're in the middle of actually
reviewing it which is i take the
mirror's point that that was made it
quite difficult for us because we will
put something out that then this private
plan change
could change in the middle of
notification and submissions which could
be a little bit complex for us however i
do know that the growth in our district
does merit the need to try and progress
this plan change and i think the staff's
recommendation is the right way to go
ahead with it
um i do think it's going to
raise a lot of um concerns in the
community and i think it will need to
have um
wide it will have wide interest so i
think it's very important that this
council reviews it very carefully
and makes a submission looking at the
future development of our whole area
because it is going to make some changes
it is going to make changes so but i was
as the mere signal too a little
uncomfortable with the idea of just
signing off a
council submission without it going
through the whole council because this
is a significant plan change
so i'm much more comfortable with
changing the wording so that we can help
progress it and then bring that back to
the full council thanks casaba
council bro yeah this report highlights
the changing dynamics of our district to
me
and uh i feel really sorry for you guys
and you know especially we're
putting time frames on you and it
infuriates me when you see
in particular an election cycle where
yeah the national politicians running
around saying councils are stymieing
this and stymieing that and stopping
that
stopping this we're not we're trying to
get it right
and uh and yep that's all i've got to
say
fear the speakers counselor concern i
just want to sort of back up um council
brian's
uh words there and the fact that that
he's 100 right and we're trying to
design a district
in the form and function that's given to
us
the outlines of government yet
the word stymie is exactly what's used
we stymie
people from doing anything particularly
developers who wish to make
lots and lots of money out of what it is
that they do with no real
um desire with the outcome
to look after the people who already
live there this particular plan changes
of interest to me
given that yes it is on state highway 1
but is
on the edge almost of a district and is
a very interesting
uh place in which to be putting things
when you have two major towns which
already have provision
be it that we need more uh more land
i'm not sure that it's a strategic place
for our district to be developing
large format so all of those things
given
um i i agree with where we're heading on
this that
we actually have a look at what it is
and what our submission would be
once this hits our table because we will
be hammered
on the uh what we call it the emotional
side we will be hammered on
for doing things and but that will be
the tact that is taken professionally
by those who wish to make plenty of
money out of this rather than
those who are emotionally involved with
the district that needs to make sure
that it grows in a way that is right for
the people who live within it
very good comments made by all and uh
totally agree uh particularly with
remarks you made
councillor barnet around process and we
look at
um e sort of signifi what
brings out i guess the four main uh
concerns
mine is particularly the scale of the
of the proposed development and
potentially absorbing
um that which we have in other areas
that we've identified them and
actually have worked really hard on
getting right
rangiora kaya poi we've spent a lot of
time
with coming up with strategies excellent
strategies
elected member involvement community
involvement
developers so something we need to think
very carefully about
i've got lots of people that come and
approach me and and the council
around their aspirations around
development
i wouldn't want to see just because
of what's proposed here that they feel
dissuaded from
making those choices you know another
area that's important
that we don't have a current strategy
for but it's growing
uh is south um we've given the
encouragement we don't have a strategy
down in that area and that's really
important it's probably one of our a
growing
area of of um employment rich
and all the opportunities that are down
there so it's certainly something i
think is important
um i i'm i think the process you're
following i realize there's no choice in
terms of
well we could make a choice but really
and truly it's it's not worth
considering that because it'll just tie
us up and
further process that we don't need to be
in um
but around bringing that back to council
for its view and sign off i think
it's important so thank you for
incorporation at council of hana
fear the speakers
okay if write a reply i'll put the
recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried
all right um thanks trevor
thank you thank you both um item 8.4
which is the
budget for chipotle town cedar carpet
shawn
and simon pages 339-342
curadan thank you for that so
we are in the process of developing a
car park
um just behind the kaiapoi new world
which is a bit of a joint project
between the
park and ride and the kaiapoi town
centre
um back in february the budget
i think was set for the kaiapoi town
center component of 100
000 um which at that stage we were still
quite early in
in producing the design of the car park
and
estimates for the car park and
as things have gone on we've realized
that amount needs to be a bit more
um simon's allowed for a 200 000
within the kaiapoi town centre budget to
pay for the car park
we decided once we got a tinder price
that would go back and
and uh so we'd know the amount to
request the funding that needed to be
brought forward so
um based on their tinder amount and
additional for pdu
contract management fees and those type
of things we're requesting that
95 000 me brought forward to make the a
total of 195
000 excuse me for this year um to pay
for that construction
do you wish to add anything simon
questions
colleagues okay we have a recommendation
uh council blackie seconded by council
reconciling council blackie
sean and simon um pretty much a
no-brainer and we're committed to this
of course
we're and with park and right um agendas
with it with our big neighbor
and bringing the money forward is the
obvious thing to do no problem
okay uh council concerned
any further speakers council stuart
thank you
i've had a few um inquiries about the
work that's already
started there i just wonder whether we
can do some publicity
around it and put it in context with the
um
uh you know the contractor um and what
it's all about because
people's um have been asking and i just
wondered
whether there was any have you had any
publicity out before
more so in regard to the park and ride
aspect so we've done some things like um
you might have noticed this signage has
been put up outside of each park and
ride site
to to show what's coming up in the time
frame and um
some brochures here that people can take
away um
i just wonder whether our comms can put
something together because
um well if you don't walk past it you
don't know and the people that have seen
it have asked me and
i'd be round the corner and i said well
well it is but
um could we have a bit more um
wider publicity for it thank you yeah we
could do a facebook
post about that particularly we have
done one about the river roadside which
is happening
at the moment as well i also know in the
in the
northern outlook a week or two ago i
think there was a write-up about park
and ride and
what's happening in the community
section particularly for kaya point
and put it on that website that we none
of us like
we won't make a reflection on that but
carry on simon
very happy to work with our comms people
to put something out there to the
community about about what's happening
there
you might note a wee while ago when we
came with the original report there was
an opportunity that we were going to
provide businesses
in the immediate area to potentially
lease some of those car parks as well
a porsche small portion of those car
parks so we can form our
communication to consider that as well
yeah i i fully support the
recommendation really good work
that's gone into this been well
discussed
there's another really good local paper
in the district called the north
canterbury news
i'm sure there are esteemed reporters
sitting there taking notes that
may well give a little bit more
publicity this but council stuart's
absolutely right i was at a
function in kaiapoi on sunday and a
number of people have no idea
um and so a comms a comms plan or
further communications around the
advocate facebook or
in related facebook pages would be
really good if that could be considered
also was feedback to me just
just with new developments occurring
it's not nothing new to you simon is
around disabled car parking
in the town centre so i know that we've
discussed that
before so it's a matter that regularly
raises because with the popularity
of things as the town has shifted some
of the businesses have shifted down
there's just a lack of of uh park
parking that people can
who are would use a disabled um pass
the able ability for them to park down
there is limited there is
time limited time parking in the area
but it's certainly something that was
raised with me by several
uh either it had a little uh huddle that
i was in on on sunday after the cowboy
seafarer service so
but thank you i'm looking forward to
this um we've been completed
um i think it'll be really valued by our
community and thanks for the work you're
doing
any further speakers uh
council becky writes reply to sandra's
comments um
been a few comments about the trees
coming out from people who don't
want trees in the unders park so when
you're doing the comms thing
just take that into account to explain
why we're taking trees out of them
okay i'll put the recommendation all
those in favor please say aye
contrary but clear that carried thanks
sean and simon
thank you all right and now it's
uh item 8.5 which is the cemetery center
sorry see another go the cemetery
strategy
i haven't been on the source i can
assure you of that not yet anyway
all right uh that's page 343-383
so we've got lynley marie and grant
who's leaving
see lindley thank you
[Laughter]
good afternoon the cemetery strategy um
has now been completed
and um it's brought forward today for
you for adoption
our cemeteries tell us a story they're
either historical
which encompasses folk that have died in
the wars
they've had accidents in our district or
have perished from disease
we have more modern cemeteries which
show us a changing trend in our
communities
increasing ashes and tournaments and
non-denominational internments
we acknowledge the challenges we have
with cemetery management not the least
been our legal obligations
we know that the burial information act
is under
review at the moment with the ministry
of health
driving that through we may well have
more onerous
requirements after that is complete
we have community expectations people
wanting different things
we have to make a nod to natural hazards
and we have the rather victorious supply
and demand
model that we've been working on and to
work out what we've got
how long it's going to last us and
whether we need to
develop more cemetery land in the not
too distant future
overall our community with our
consultation that we did
they talked about peaceful and
reflective areas
safe and environmentally friendly
records that they can research and for
their genealogy
and follow up what happened with their
family so over the years
and we also need to meet our legislative
requirements of course
so i'm hoping today that we will adopt
our symmetry strategy
and the action plan that implements that
strategy that sits behind it you'll note
in the action plan
and the strategy itself sorry that we do
say that that action plan will be
reviewed every year
that will monitor how we're doing where
we're going
and to ensure that we are actually
covering the requirements for
burial and cremations in our district
with the
20 years of the strategy thank you and
thanks lindy uh mariel grant did you
wish to anything
okay so questions counselor
thank you lindley i have asked this last
time but i just want clarification
with all these pre-paid cemetery plots
that have been
achieved just what percentage you know
they must some of them must be going
back many many years and perhaps never
be used so
have you got any idea of
i haven't got the numbers with me
unfortunately but
there are only a handful that are really
old i asked our customer services
officers to have
a look for me it's quite challenging
trying to work back in historical
records
um but there is only a handful that are
more than 60 years old
the um the rest are more modern uh and
yes we're definitely turning our minds
to that
difficult issue of when do we decide
that actually this family isn't going to
be using it
what sort of impulse can we put on
families to say
can you tell us are you ever going to
use this plot
it's it is quite difficult and at the
moment we have our moratorium
and as we're developing the cemetery
policy which will be the next
piece of work of the rank that takes
into account this possibility
of land banking
so to speak your symmetry plot
thank you just use lane banking yes
the other thing is i just want to
question is that we've had a number of
headstones that have been knocked off
their purchase with with earthquake
um and it's a sort of a bit of a
difficult situation because
we do we need to we can't just go ahead
and tidy them up without consulting with
the the um
the iran people
i was trying trying to how to how to
word that
the family how do you how do we get
around that
um so that's something that we're going
to look at for the policy as well wendy
because it is
it's a very fair question um some of the
headstones might not have anybody that
we can naturally talk to
um so
i say naturally
they i think i'd be more worried if they
responded
so yeah look there's there's there's
some investigations that we'll have to
do there because it's uh
it's kind of a problem for cemeteries
right up and down the country as well as
to
what do we do with headstones when we've
technically
they're an asset that somebody else owns
but you know it's how cold we become
with that
as it were so that's certainly something
that we need to look into
thank you very much for that council
followed by council redmond so
thank you very much for the strategy it
looks great i just wanted to check
because i
this is obviously operational not
operational but i had a question the
other day about
if someone wants to renew a
a plotter or a headstone or anything
like that that's of
of the family but not their immediate
relative what's the process for that
what do they do like they want to
actually make it
tidier or prettier or remove lichen and
but they just how do they
permission they're able to maintain them
with
any grave there's there's somebody who
is the rights holder
okay and it's either the person who
purchased the plot
um or a next of kin and
we need to be careful particularly with
the historic ones that
there aren't um aren't changes being
made sometimes
with the best intentions um families
might want to
upgrade or change the wording or
add additional rooting to the
graves but you know if it's just
maintenance then they're able to do it
to do that we just need to
find out what they're doing because
obviously if they're working in the
cemetery there's
things that we need to know about what
they're doing you know they're not going
to damage anything else while they're
doing that they're not going to harm
themselves
so normally if it's lichen
then people can go ahead
if it's painting or anything like that
then we
suggest they talk to a monumental mason
okay okay thank you council redmond
followed by council pride
uh thank you i just wondered when does
the moratorium on land banking
end does it end when this
strategy is passed
or when is it likely to cease
i think it ends once the stretchy end
the policy was
our decision at the last meeting once
those are through
then that and in the moratorium even
though it's
um it stops people uh pre-booking
a lot of plots if it's a husband and
wife they
i think it was the the wife or the
husband of the person purchasing can
purchase
an additional plot or the parents if
it's a child so it's
it's not a strict no you can't do it but
it's just
it takes a little bit more control
rather than a group
coming and saying we want 20 plots for
our
particular group so it's um it's not a
strict
no we can't do anything it's
just a little bit tighter than it was
previously but once the policy is
through we'll be
um that will it may well restrict it
still
or we'll just see how we go from there
just one other point is that we'll
probably be looking at
fees and the long-term plans so
the council might decide to keep that
until after fees
decisions be made on whether fees are
increased as well
you can't slip around you're hoping to
avoid the gold rush effect don't you
just looking at the map in 352
out towards the east um
there's no no symmetries we're going to
be starting to
to look given two reports back we were
talking about how
rapidly woody and ravenswood pegasus is
growing yeah and look that's one of the
key things that we've put into the
action plan as well
and that's a bit of work that we're
going to be looking into as well um
robbie is
what what provision can we provide over
in the east
we know that we've got zefton out there
obviously there's ongoing discussions
around
dixon's road but it's also what happens
with uh
you know we start to talk about the
increase in population around pegasus
ravenswood would end
um plus also kaiapoi and the conditions
that we've got in the ground there as
well so
that's definitely a bit of work that
we'll be doing
okay council stuart thank you
so there's no standardization across the
country about
what um like this policy or your
requirements are specific to here
because i'm doing exactly
trying to put ashes in an old grave my
mother
in in christchurch city and they won't
let me touch it
um you're not allowed to it gets sprayed
for lycan
not and you're not allowed to paint it
you're not allowed to do anything at all
it stays like it is and
if i want to add something else to it
not allowed to
it has to be strictly passed by the
registrar there
so are we there's no standardization
across
the country it's specific to whatever we
decide here compared to what happens
elsewhere
that's right there's no standardization
as such but
i think if you look if you look at what
other councils are doing and we have
taken the opportunity to look at quite a
few
that it is quite standard when you when
you look at
processes and memorial sizes that type
of thing
we require people to apply to us
to do any work um add anything to a
headstone
and or take anything away
or any maintenance other than cleaning
they do have to apply and get permission
to do that
i would also say as well that we're um
especially through marie's team we're a
little bit more connected with
customer base as it were so some of the
policy and some of the things that we're
suggesting
aren't going to be as black and white
and
sorry off the table we tend to humanize
and work with our people a little bit
more
yes i was quite taken aback really but
however
um you know okay um
missed me yeah sorry i'm just sorry yes
sorry further questions
no no i was just reflecting on something
that grant said
strategy was but anyway i wasn't gonna
dare ask that question
all right um some are prepared to move
counselor duty seconded by
councillor um brian cassidy
thank you very much for this um this is
quite a
um an exercise that you've got to do and
with looking forward
uh with where you're going to place
other
cemetery areas and
and the land the amount of land that
you're going to be needing
for future generations so there's a lot
of work to be done on that but and i
really appreciate
the work and effort you've put together
thank you
because the brain a very important
planning process you've all heard the
saying uh there are only two certainties
and i won't go into it most of it but
very important piece of work
for the speakers uh reply
my right applies just going to be a
little comment that alright
it's fine when um ian and i bought our
plot plots and we did say to our
daughter
that we bought a piece of real estate
and she said
what you haven't told us and so we said
well come with us and we'll show you
where they are
and all we got was you two are sick
thank you thank you council attorney
uh with that i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried thank you
thanks lindy thanks marie and thanks
grant
appreciate your work right
right now we're at item 8.6 which is the
joint name canterbury regional joint
landfill committee pages 384-402
kitty and sister kitty
hi kitty
it's pretty straightforward request
hopefully good afternoon
um it's a short report um
it's basically bringing the constituting
agreement
for the canterbury regional landfill
joint committee in line with
the canterbury waste joint committee
agreement and allowing people to attend
virtually meetings so i'll
take any questions thank you any
questions uh moved by council violence
second
council brian okay to council barna
very briefly to say it's great to see
that um people are modernising finally
and um getting this through into their
standing orders
house of brian we're the speakers
right of reply nothing to respond to so
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carried thank you
kitty
um item 8.7 customer satisfaction survey
um
vj pages 403 to 7 11.
good afternoon welcome so
um the first point i'd like to make that
this is a very important survey for the
council it's the largest one that we do
that the fine example actually represent
the views of the population as a whole
also the findings have been consistent
over time so it reinforces
its credibility so this
time round is the first time that we've
actually prepared a
public facing document which we've tried
to do to make it a bit more
user-friendly
you can't sort of see the full effect on
your screens because it's designed as a
two-page document
a two-page spread i should say
but overall i think the council should
be really pleased with
your overall results your overall
performance is
85 which is the same as your previous
survey
and the satisfaction is really minimal
so if you're sort of thinking what does
that mean well by comparison i read in
the
local newspaper a wee a few weeks ago
that the christchurch city council
it's not exactly apples with apples
because they do an annual survey
resident survey and they use a different
methodology but
they had 50 and they had
decreased from 62 from the previous year
so
the city council article in the paper
said they're really concerned about
results and they're looking at how they
can get residents more engaged so i
think
you know this council's doing really
well so
um the the big winners with very high
satisfaction and minimal dissatisfaction
with waste management
over there and water supply and library
services
so i think we should give some
congratulations to those teams and my
question is how do we
sort of recognise that as an
organisation
areas that stood out as needing
improvement were consultation
the talent ranging or town centre
traffic flow and parking
regulatory performance and environmental
management
one of the things i'll say about the
town centre
trevor flynn parking is also it was the
biggest increase
in
[Music]
satisfaction so i think it is it just
depends as the area grows and you get
more and more people and you get more
more um traffic you try you do things to
address it and the dissatisfaction goes
down and then you get more people and
it's a bit of a circular thing
um environmental environmental
management if we do the survey in three
years time it'd be really interesting to
see whether the results
reflect the current investment that this
council is making
into the area but one of the points i'll
make is that this will only happen if
the general public becomes aware of the
improvements made so
i think it's really important that the
council informs the public
to think about how the council informs
the public about the work it's doing
across the board residents wanted more
information to be provided about
council's activities in a variety of
ways but the question
is how do you do this best in a world of
information overload
and we do provide a lot of information
and one example i can think of as
community development where the
users of the service of the services
they provide
have really high satisfaction rates but
overall there's
in this overall resident survey there's
a really large
don't know non-response and i think
somehow it'd be good to try and get the
general public in the district knowing
about
services they don't necessarily use but
fund
and so my last point is um
we need to put some effort into thinking
about how to use the survey results to
inform council's business
and let members of the public know we've
heard what they're saying
so that they'll think it's worthwhile to
contribute their time because
people's commitment to filling in
surveys is decreasing over time
and one example
i got from the christchurch city
council's website is
they say uh
for example in a particular area they
say this is the satisfaction rate this
is what we provide
this is what you think what you say and
this is how it links to our community
outcomes
and this is what we've actually done so
if we start linking some of the work
that we're doing
when we advertise it and go
you said this and this is what we've
provided then we start making those kind
of connections
and this is another example where
they've just got a one-page snapshot
so what people say we did really well
what people think we can improve and
what people think we're unsatisfied
which is the red bit so just trying to
get
um yeah yeah yeah so trying to get the
message
a bit out more and i'll be working with
comms to look at how we might
do some of that messaging thank you
thanks vj um just do we write back to
those that we survey and give them any
feedback um
it's an anonymous survey all right i'll
tell you
no all right any further questions
because this job
yes i was just going to ask whether
there was taking your point
there on page about you know people
being
generally um not as aware as we would
like about particular
services that the council provides
you're using that but in fact that can't
work for city council because you've
just
you've just told us about how you've
only had they've only had 50
satisfaction so how was that well it
won't necessarily increase the
satisfaction rate
because um like one of the big areas
that
people were to satisfy with the city
council was their decision making
so if we if we did things
took actions that people were generally
not happy about you'll see that
reflected in the next survey no doubt
and we've seen that in the past um
but we i think it'll help improve the
non-response rate
and if we start linking it people will
go well actually they
are doing things so for example
environmental management the
satisfaction rating
was okay but i wouldn't expect it next
time to go
up if people are aware that we're
actually putting more resources into
those areas which the council has done
recently
the question i was going to ask follow
on that was
is there any um council in new zealand
that is
um has got it this
issue that you're bringing up sorted so
that we could in fact take a leaf out of
that book
um you're advocating
this one but is that are there any
others
um well i think there's some yeah i mean
i don't know to answer your question i
mean
i think we can look at the way we
communicate our results
better and there yeah i don't know
what other councils do to communicate
their results
further questions against the williams
front of the council tv
just curious it's got um the cost comes
out of their
normal budget what is the cost of that
um said effect action survey well
normally it's
uh usually it's staff time however this
time round
we had a researcher actually do the
background research report for us
and i don't know
the cost of there off the top of my head
because
[Music]
jeff meadows signed that off at the end
of the day
so it is a significant cost to the
council because there was
myself and our researcher and lindley
and gina working on it
and now we'll be looking at working
closely with comms so
it is it is a significant
time cost so i think
it's another reason why it's good to
make the survey really count
in the business that we do yeah so that
don't answer me question when he does it
i can actually get a figure well
circulate to us i can't tell you how
many hours we've spent because we
haven't recorded that
but i can tell you the consultant's cost
to do the research report if you're able
vj at some stage if you could circulate
that that would be
the research cost yeah yeah great thank
you
um council duty thank you um
just on 418 with a small settlement
footpaths what do you constitute as a
small
settlement because it's actually quite a
low
the top and the lows it's quite quite
low quite different
yeah we think of that as
you know the cuss in the um system
yeah those little ceilings and the beach
sediment beach
okay um i could i just say i've thought
of another cost that we actually pay the
community groups to
deliver the questionnaires and um
we give them a certain amount per survey
and we pay their travel costs and i can
get you those figures as well
thank you uh council reckons yeah just
that
you've commented about tying things in
to
different departments it's my
understanding that in the regulatory
department well certainly as councillors
and it's been said around this table
more than once in the last three to four
years that we've had
the least complaints about the
regulatory department than we ever have
yet in the survey their results are
down by from anywhere from
14 to 4
so how can we tie that back to the
actual performance because that's
not certainly what we are hearing
yeah so i guess that's the public the
general
population's perceptions out there
of as opposed to people
really might be a bit of a double up but
people who actually
use the service so the people who are
coming in and using the service
you're saying there's you know less
complaints
but this survey is across the whole
so the the opinions of these residents
reflect the district as a whole
so um and
what just further to that my experience
is
that their last interaction
that was particularly negative is the
one they most remember and that might be
10 years ago when they last built
their house which may not necessarily be
a current
um perception
of of uh performance so
all survey results need to be
considered uh um
from a number of perspectives and and
you're right to highlight that
particularly our regulatory
functions often you know there is a if
you went and asked
new zealand's community how well do
councils regulatory systems operate that
you know you probably get a negative
response on
uh from a large proportion even though
they don't actually know or never
actually use the
services and i think i did sorry
so the question around that then is
given that explanation
this is now a public facing document
which is going to have these results in
there which
i mean and i get that some of them are
subjective but i mean that's a
pretty big
discrepancy
discrepancy i mean that clearly in my
mind when i look at the informatics on
that
looks like the regulatory department is
not going so well
that's what it looks like if you put
that out to public they're going to go
geez they're not doing a very good job
are they well
off yeah i think i had an original in my
original
draft of my report that you know
regulatory performance
people don't they don't it's not the
warm fuzzies that you get from
libraries so you know because you're
you're sort of restricting people's
activities so there's that aspect of it
as well
but one of the things people are asking
us for is to be transparent and they're
the actual results of the general survey
so it's like we're not trying to
maybe we can alter the page to
actually put some t yeah
we have to be careful about being
selective
about what we um report on
when it's a general resident survey but
there could be
a way that we can address your concerns
anyway you'll take it on board vijay so
thank you
um all right um any further questions
council barnet you indicated you wish to
move second oh
i'll second that counts about it yes and
council atkinson is absolutely right
this is what people think of us when
they get a survey in front of them on
that day
whatever they've done that particular
day and what interactions they've had in
that particular
month or years previous so it is
perception
but how it is useful is you just look
for some trends you look for the trends
of things going up
and down um we already do user surveys
in each of our departments which then
add to the amount of data that we've got
so i'm quite comfortable with this being
public it's what those people thought on
the day of the council it's a snapshot
in time
um really interesting to see the the
talk about it being predetermined and
that
indicates to us that perhaps we need to
do a little bit more work
as we talked about in our communication
strategy on what is information and what
is consultation
um interesting to see cycling coming up
and the
wanting us to do more in the climate
change and environmental in the water
space
and that's reflecting the climate of our
society which is changing
and it's really interesting to see that
coming through the survey
um what you want to look for in the
survey as an overall
is for where the satisfaction is going
down and the dissatisfaction is coming
up because as um vijay rightly noted
the dissatisfaction on ring euro and
parking has gone up but so here's the
satisfaction
so that's not as much a concern as one
where they're going like this
and the one that stood out to me was
rural roads sealed
the dissatisfaction is going up and the
satisfaction is going down
so that may be another area which i
think is actually something we need to
talk about it may be out of our control
because the funding
for rural roads and maintenance and
ceiling
has gone down and that's a national
issue
i also liked the fact that people were
asking for more online services so that
justifies the work we're doing in that
space
cost businesses who don't do research
fail
businesses who don't know their
customers fail so i think this is a
very well justified spend we need to
know what our public's thinking
so we can make our community better if
we don't know
we won't yet know where to focus our
resources we cannot spread our resources
everywhere
but i agree that communicating the
results is the hardest thing
how we communicate it is quite tough and
i think really what we need to do is
look at the overall
the overall says 84.6 of our district
are satisfied with waimakariri district
council that's a huge figure
for a council and that's actually
something that we should look at
overall people are pretty pleased with
the performance of this council it
doesn't mean we can rest on our laurels
it doesn't mean we haven't got some
specific issues where we can see trends
going up and down
but it does mean that we can actually be
rightly proud of the work that's being
done in the organisation
and that's what we need to communicate
that's what we need to say to our public
is that overall we are actually
performing as you want us to
but we will con continue to improve
um i support the comments of councillor
barnett um
it's a very proven methodology and i'm
really
pleased to see that it was mary's barry
that's come back in to do the consultant
work because
she actually developed the strategy uh
in the methodology in the first place
and i remember um when ellen macrobee
was a counsellor here
would go into that with mary in detail
and i think mary and
alan were students or certainly students
around the same time perhaps but they
they certainly agreed on that
methodology and how that was
developed and alan was certainly a the
expression in that space so
it's really good to see mary there i'm
all for transparency in terms of costs
so
i think that's a fair questions that
council williams
uh has raised um but overall i think
uh the response rate at 75.8 percent
that's pretty impressive
not many polls get that level of
response rate when they're trying to
obtain what communities or what opinions
is let alone
getting that response rate from our
community so
i think we would be very impressed with
some of our comms work that we do if we
got that
in general that level of response rate
and 85
satisfaction yes not resting on their
laurels but
gosh that's it's fantastic and that's a
credit to all their organisation i'm
proud of all our staff
and all our constituent parts that make
up that that's a really good result
yet there's some findings in there that
um
obviously we need to reflect on and
council atkinson's
rightly raised some some concerns around
that
but i think the important thing from
this vj is the findings
and that uh how we learn from them so
that at various departments where
there's some feedback there
how we learn from them how we capture
that how we turn that around
that's really important for our waste
and library areas well done
um to other departments as well as
mentioned in there that have also done
well
that's really really good but in general
um
getting more information and as you
mentioned there was one of the main
points that come from residents
that's something for our comms and
departments to reflect on
and how we do better and in fact they're
quite a reflective bunch
our comms team so i'm sure they'll take
it on board and
how they uh and we can do better in that
space as we
discussed about a week or so ago so
thanks vijay
really pleased with this report fear the
speakers
all right i'll put the right of reply
accounts about that i'll put the
recommendation all those in favor please
say aye
contrary to clear that carry eight point
one
twenty twenty one council meeting
schedule gosh that's
20 21 rolling around shortly sarah
thank you pages
however the sooner that we get this uh
settled the sooner we can get it in your
calendars and you know we will
plan for next year so we have brought it
to you a month earlier than normal
um when we were looking at the schedule
for next year we
took in a number of factors feedback
from
councillors this year
changes of patterns to some meetings
and we've made just a few little tweaks
our morning meetings normally start at 9
30 we've brought that back to 9am
to enable the time
not being so pressurised when it's
getting there at 12 o'clock
we've still got the leeway to go till 12
30 and a majority of the afternoon
meetings that were starting at four
we've brought back to 3 30. so again
just that little bit of adjustment
allows for that balance
we've managed to bring in the land and
water committee that's currently on a
thursday
into the tuesday schedule we've kept
the tuesday schedule which works well
and there will be after
march of next year a decrease in the
need for the dpnr committee meetings
[Music]
august is the main regulatory
feedback report back time so that will
tend to be a slightly longer meeting but
we have then
spaced the others out accordingly based
on feedback from the senior managers
however while there's a decline in dpnr
committee meetings
there will be an increase in the unr
committee meetings
uh currently other than
february march and sort of november
december
it's normally every second month it will
be monthly next year
and that's primarily linked to the three
waters reporting
or shovel ready project reporting so
there will be an increased
need there uh
district licensing committee we have
kept to our last friday of the month
and if there are not hearings scheduled
on those months
it is an opportunity for training
for the committee and the west that we
also
had or feedback that we received from
members
was it would be nice to be able to have
a break
through the year like some councils
manage
to work into their program we've managed
to get
two different weeks that coincide
school holidays in april and july
there may be during the year
a couple of other weeks that are lighter
on work
flows just depending if there's any
hearings or
additional working group type meetings
that are coming through
so we have managed to schedule a couple
of little
breaks with no meetings so otherwise i
take the reporter through it
thanks sarah any questions of cyril
council stuart council followed by
council blacking
thank you yes water zone did discuss
this yesterday
and they are meeting monthly
with workshops in between as you
probably know
it would be really helpful if those
workshops were put in here as well
because they're still going to be
they're not committing meetings
publicly and they may in fact be public
workshops
to be decided but if you're doing it
doing a a timetable they need to go in
there
this for a formal report is just formal
meetings
the briefings and any additional working
groups and things are still to be worked
through
with um particularly with the water zone
being a joint committee
so that feedback is yet to come back
from staff
on the other side as well so work in
conjunction
and the the meeting schedule that you
see is a separate attachment to
this report that will be expanded as
those dates
are known and work through over a period
of time
as will any regular working group
meetings that are going to be a
continuum through the year
at the moment we have quite an influx of
them but some of them
may have a shorter life span for a few
months but if they're going to be a
continuous we will
put those in your schedules and they'll
come through into your diary
appointments as well
and due time this is just the formal
meetings
because that's before you today okay any
further questions counselor concern
well just just on how they get on our
diary do they come through as
individuals
we have to ping off everyone or will
these be entered as one
bang it's in your diary um given the
amount that you have to put in your
direction
they have they are put in as individual
meetings because
some meetings are not consistent like
the first
tuesday of every month um might be
easier than
others to put in oxford when we put that
in is slightly different again
um but they're put on as a council
cluster
um but
starting staff get pretty proficient at
putting those in for you
any further questions i'll move from the
chair that we
accept the recommender that we made the
recommendation from the chair any
council duty of a second just briefly
sarah thank you for all the work that
you've done
piecing all this together it's a it's a
very big task and i do appreciate
um that you've also managed to
just work in some short breaks there
because that's the feedback i've got
from the number
i just wouldn't mind that occasional
just gap really
just so that there can be a bit of an
opportunity for refresher other councils
do it and i think it's really
it's good practice so um i've got no
hesitation
moving your recommendation i certainly
wouldn't want to try and change it
um secure who was counsel dirty do you
wish to speak
just to say thank you very much sarah
this is quite a mammoth
procedure you've gone through and um
thank you very much it's
i don't really quite know where you
would fit all the
these meetings together and making sure
that they balance nicely but you've done
a great job
yep okay sorry i was just doing some
mechanics here any further speakers
nothing to respond to all those to favor
please say aye
contrary to clear that carried we might
just jump
ahead because we've got some staff that
are waiting here
um and we're probably going to need to
have a break soon so just
um just for perhaps uh
libby we might do your report next 9.1
and 9.2 they're following so
um
yes all right so 9.1 pages 7424-742
let lobby and kelly
many of you have already seen this
closure come around a couple of times
it's been to the ahoka
oxford community board and utilities and
writing committee
um so just a brief brief overview it's a
closure of a stock quarter race that
runs adjacent to cena place
um the closure doesn't
automatically mean that parts can be
filled in any
landowner who wants to fill in any
portion will need to approach council
and get approval from drainage staff
any questions thank you is there any
questions council williams followed by
council duty
okay um there's a wee bit of flooding in
that area
and what consuming fear they may be able
to follow that
they don't have with that effect
upstream
on that there if we give permission for
one land owner to basically
a water race when it may be getting used
as a bit of a flood protection
we either should we make a ruling we
either
leave them there or or fill them in
i'm sorry i think kelly has responded to
a similar question at a previous meeting
he'd
i possibly know the answer um
the drainage staff will assess any
application that comes in and
potentially there will be an order in
which
residents may need to fill in to
alleviate any drainage
issues in terms of damning and such and
yeah so we won't be allowing any
landowners to fill anything and that
would have any adverse effects
downstream on any other properties
and secondary questions to that and what
we'll be checking to make sure that i
don't fall some of these in without
telling us
so if this report is approved today we
will be sending out a letter to
all of the affected property owners and
outlining the process for them to get in
contact with us
um if there is some work undertaken
by one of the property owners that does
have an adverse effect
i'm sure we will find out about it
either as part of the regular
inspections that we do
or during any future rainfall events
okay further further questions
council do
thank you very much we've gone through
this uh
with the community board and also with
the
roading and and um um
it is um as you know i'm not really keen
on these closing them but
in this case that's it's quite
acceptable to do so
and that's why i will um have moved the
recommendation
because the meetings
nice thank you um yes look this has been
been well discussed
um many times over and and the fact of
the matter is
it's not used for stock water anymore
and that is the only reason why there's
a consent issued for stock water
races so it makes sense to close it if
it's no longer required for its
consented purpose
and i have no problems in recommending
it
thanks for the speakers okay
uh nothing to respond to council duty so
i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say i contrary
to clear that carried
thanks libby and kelly i don't know if
you're going to stay for colin's report
okay so now we're 9.2 743-814 on the
agenda
uh colin and kelly cool
thank you and like the last report this
one was referred from the utilities and
wrote in committee
so i think um just better from here is
familiar with it
from that meeting so i wasn't going to
talk through it a lot um the only thing
i thought i'd note is
um the only change you would potentially
have seen is that the document is now
in the current uh the council's current
branding rather than the old branding so
none of the content
has changed but only the um the branding
which we noted in the last one would be
updated
um so aside from that i'm happy to
take it as read and respond to any
questions
any questions someone prepared to move
moved by council williams seconded by
council duty
castle williams council duty
any further speakers just say thank
thanks colin for the work
well done we appreciate it as as always
i'll put the recommendation or uh all
those in favor please say i
contrary to clear that carriage um
jim we might deal with the health and
safety is sarah's still around
out there is still around
um maybe we could deal with i think
we'll come back to the ceo one
later because i'm just conscious that
we're gonna need a break soon so perhaps
deal with
8.10
we deal with 8.10 sarah which is
counselors to outside groups and then
we'll deal with the health and safety
report and then
we might call have a break at that point
8.10
thank you sarah
uh
thank you any questions because of duty
mr mr mia through through you can can i
please ask councillor
mealing a question i'm sure thank you
council emily um
with this you're being appointed as an
observer
to the coastal hazard working party what
does that
mean are you just sitting there can you
make comments can you vote
what is that position for you to be
sitting to going into christchurch to do
my understanding with that thank you
very much by the way um
my understanding with that is basically
you know i'm a non-voted non-voting
member of this group and
and just really sitting in on their
conversations of of what they're
proposing and and how they're looking at
doing things
um and it's very much an exercise in
understanding what the left hand and the
right hand are doing because
whilst yes we have territorial authority
boundaries
we share the same coastline it's the
same issues that we're dealing with and
so it's really just making sure that
we're on the same page and being that it
is
also um in the um
climate change area which is in my
portfolio and part of the greater
christchurch partnership work stream
it kind of makes sense for that to be me
appointed to that but as
as far as
an observer status i i presume
if if called upon i can make comment and
whatnot as we do with the gp
so so the request came by myself uh
and i um confirmed with um sarah and it
was
my recommendation what our
recommendation here today
that council meetings because a it's
within her portfolio area
and secondly she's part of the greater
christchurch partnership
so it was logical and it is an observer
status
and actually we're lucky that the city
are allowing that actually and have
brought that together because it's an
important issue that they raised at our
joint meeting so
that's why um councilman's has been
recommended for that
thank you my question from that was
really i just want to make sure that she
was going to be utilized well i'm not
just sitting there
in a seat well
hopefully i'll i'll have the opportunity
to um okay
pop myself so any further questions to
sarah uh councillor stewart
so i'm very happy to be a biodiversity
champion
as part of the mayoral forum workstream
administered by environment canopy but
what on earth does it involve
please
i just thought that would be an area
that you would be interested in sandra
um councilman
exactly you need some work sandra um
just
again on c i'm just wondering obviously
that was that was an opportunity that
came through a mural forum work stream
would there be other opportunities come
forward occasionally for
councillors to be involved if if they do
i'll certainly present them here
so um mostly through mural forum is it
it is actually internal
within the mirror mirrors themselves but
we have been talking around the
climate change to perhaps broaden that
to include
portfolio holders and respective
councils but when those opportunities
come along to utilize those skills
absolutely and i've put it forward
okay any further questions so we have a
recommendation
uh a b and c somewhere prepared to move
moved by councilman
seconded by council duty any discussion
uh council do you know just just
congratulations to the both of you for
whatever you're going to be doing hold
it hold the congratulations you might
just want to make sure it passes first
moved in seconded uh any further
discussion
all those in favor aye contrary to clear
that carried you you both now
counts to do these congratulations are
well justified
um sarah might leave 8.9 until
um because jim do you want to do health
cover health and safety and then we
might have a break
thanks mr mayor so this report the
standard report
uh to note uh rangiora service center
renovations are well underway and work
crew are there dealing with the upstairs
and people
are spread to the four winds of rangiora
and generally the feedback i've received
when
visiting those sites are people are
appreciative of the alternate
accommodation and
um having having a temporary home so
that's
going okay the balance of the report is
there for your information and you'll
note the
the sad event that occurred in kaiapoi
which our library staff
provided um as much support as they
could to
the member of the public who
sadly had a serious accident and
subsequently passed away as
so that's there for noting the rest of
the report
um is there for your information have
you to take any questions
are your questions counselor stuart
do you smoke caffeine yes the one twenty
fourth
of eight under the um the person that
died
the weed spraying without water unit
knowledge or approval
who was doing that i'm not
is that some like delta or cycle or
something
i'm not entirely sure who the contractor
was
i i think it's a contractor um
who has been involved in a
in a shared space and so i'm not not
entirely sure which contractor it was
it's i noticed pending investigation
because we've had complaints about um
sprayed areas where no one seems to
have any idea who's been doing it an
investigation within that organization
hasn't revealed anything
so this is really intriguing
yes i'm not i'm not sure because about
i'll i'll find i'll find out what i can
about it
um i suspect we may not find out
too much about it as we have with the
others but i'll certainly make that
inquiry
very quickly that just this may not be
as relevant but the chicken hatch that
we put put on
the trek to pan and drain how where do
you think our residents are about what
they can do
in things like road reserves and roading
areas i noticed that someone has planted
trees again
on the road reserve on oxford road um
in front of a historic sign which is
going to have to be fixed
um so how how do we communicate to our
public what they are in ireland
aren't allowed to do in the road reserve
type areas
it's a constant challenge i think uh
right across
our community as people encroach into
adjacent spaces and
um ownership becomes 19th whole
possession becomes nine tenths of the
law
is and we see that often in our beach
communities
and tikka haka has a constant struggle
trying to keep
uh the invasion of gardens into public
spaces and reserves and same with
roadways and any other
patch of ground and sometimes those
people actually do really good job of
actually maintaining those public spaces
and save us some money and
and in doing that but sometimes they do
some things which
aren't necessarily helpful and we
i don't think we have a education
campaign alive in this space at all
really we when we get in get somebody
who's encroaching into spaces and it's
my experience with it's mainly been in
the beach communities where property
owners look to extend gardens and to the
reserve space that's the one that we
have them
have had the most challenge with that i
recall and
usually that's a an ongoing conversation
as as we try and
reclaim those areas
well
the the effectiveness of a campaign
um in a proactive sense i think most
people know
that they probably shouldn't uh do
things beyond their own property
boundaries but they
it doesn't stop them nonetheless uh
just uh how many billy goats and
things like that that are parked up on
the road reserves with a little
a-frame hutch have we got
they would probably describe those as
their
mower which is uh mowing the berm it
just does it very slowly or at least it
takes eats the weeds
won't eat much of the grass and then
they bring the sheep into both
the tiny house
[Laughter]
all right well any any other questions
um so the recommendations there some are
appeared to move
moved council duty second to council
meetings
um any discussion no just once again
very
good report thank you very much thank
you
okay any further speakers i'll put that
all those in favor please say aye
contrary to clear that carriage so i
think we should take a break now
um now um we've got the purdum
so nick perdum and kerry hammond and
then adina coming at four
so what i intend to do is when we come
back in this
move into committee um and we'll hear
and then questions and then um they'll
leave and then we'll
get back into the agenda okay so fiogo
may well be still hanging around out
there i don't know
but they were on the weigh-ins
don't think they just want a cup of
coffee sandra somehow
anyway
okay so just just be aware of that and
um
they're just looking for footage no
doubt they're allowed to come in here
um by the way but when it goes into
public excluded
they need to depart elliston will
hopefully be up here to help us manage
that
otherwise we'll send him out
[Laughter]
all right hey
what's that oh
thank you